teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles out of the
shadows is here to give Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtle fans what they've wanted
for a long time a Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtle movies starring Tyler Perry I
mean that's what we all really wanted
right I mean hashtag Tyler Perry for
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles man that
campaign really worked there was no
campaign for that in this film the
turtles are feeling a little bit
depressed because they want to go
outside they feel like hey why can't we
be around everybody else oh that's right
we're giant turtle monsters that kind of
sucks and they feel as if they would
like to be part of society because
they've helped save many lives and
they're not getting any credit for it
Will Arnett from the last film is now
known as the Falcon by the public he's
receiving all credit for defeating
shredder who now is actually played by a
human he's not a gigantic robot and
shredder is amassing a giant army to
once again take over the world and
combine forces with the evil Krang I
grew up when Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles were the and they're still
popular today I wasn't huge into all the
products and the merchandise and the
shows and everything but I do feel
nostalgic about them about that time
period some of the games were fun I used
to play them with my friends a lot but I
was never a die-hard TMNT fan so this is
going to be reviewed coming from the
perspective of somebody who appreciates
the source material but isn't like oh I
get all the fanservice or oh I have to
have everything just right for me I'm
coming at this from a movie perspective
how was this film the Turtles feel more
like the Turtles I remember as a kid and
not so much the modern 2014 version that
we got two years ago they feel more like
a team and that's when the biggest
themes of this movie their brotherly
love for each other how they can become
a team how they can work as a team and
how they can get over their differences
which you would expect to see in a movie
like this to be honest I mean the first
one was pretty much like that to all of
them trying to figure out how to become
a team and this one they're also trying
to figure out how to become a team and I
guess they're just they're really having
a hard time becoming a team still as a
film this thing crumbles to the ground I
mean almost every scene is an exposition
scene you guys know what that is like an
x-men apocalypse the scene where Maury
retard says here's apocalypse you know
he has four horsemen blah blah blah
that's the exposition scene tells us
things
we need to know that the filmmakers are
having a hard time conveying to the
audience without just saying hey this is
what's happening right now and you have
to know this
virtually every scene in this movie is
like that Megan Fox will call the
turtles tell them information they need
Will Arnett will call somebody tell them
information they need the turtles look
at their computer screens and say oh my
gosh crane is assembling his ship he'll
be ready in five minutes and if we don't
do this this is going to happen and if
that happens and this is going to happen
and it's like okay thanks I appreciate
the information it's not hard to figure
out that's one of the things that I
can't stand about this movie it thinks
it's audience is so criminally dumb and
it treats its audience that way
everything that you see happening on the
screen is then repeated audibly just in
case you were so dumb that you couldn't
pick up on it and I can't stand
filmmaking like that in this film we get
editions like Casey Jones played by
Stephen Amell who is a likeable actor
and from what I understand a great guy
but he's pretty bad in this movie and I
feel like a lot of that is really the
direction his performance goes from very
over-the-top to sometimes way too
lowbrow and he's really hard to balance
actually as a character he doesn't
actually do much at all he just kind of
comes in and likes Megan Fox who also
doesn't do much in this movie except
look extremely hot as she usually does
and say some things to the Turtles one
definite positive of this movie for me
is the turtles themselves they were much
better than they were in the first film
they were less obnoxious they were more
fun they were a lot more like a team and
they work to be like a team in this
movie and you do kind of feel that the
film tries to have that message but it
just doesn't really care to explore it
that much and poor Laura Linney is just
wandering around yelling at people in
this film and yeah I don't really know
actually what happened in this movie
let's talk about Krang a lot of people
were excited that Krang was in this
movie he's a big blob who looks like a
brain with tentacles and he goes a lot
and that's really all Krang is it's
awful
I hated it I'm being honest with you I
really hated Krang in this movie he was
just a big CGI blob attached to a robot
what do you know another Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles movie that ends in the sky
with a robot fight because yeah shredder
were you excited about shredder
no spoilers don't get excited about
shredder
just don't it's like they made him a
person to please the fans who were angry
about him being like a robot in the
first movie but they were still kind of
testy about it so they were like we'll
make shredder a person but he will do
nothing
strangely enough though my biggest
complaint with this movie is that the
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles barely do
anything ninja worthy they basically do
a lot of parkour slash freerunning and
that's it they run really fast jump over
things slide under things I can't think
of one memorable combat scene how sad is
that I mean I wanted some ninja action
even if it's just going to be with the
CGI Turtles they could have done
something that a ninja my do besides
parkour and how the turtles keep getting
in the cargo bays of planes
I can barely wear jewelry through the
security aisle at an airport how do they
keep getting in planes I'm going to give
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles out of the
shadows addy if you were a fan I don't
know if you're going to be a fan of this
there's definitely fanservice but I
don't really know if you'll actually
appreciate it because the movie
surrounding it is such guys thank
you so much as always for watching I'm
going to have my new office tour this
weekend for you guys or my new set I'm
excited to bring that to you guys
you're the best if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck mine eyes